The Joe Rogan Experience I used to say
that I think I could beat up a style
Bender if we were drinking we'd drink
the same amount of beers and then get in
the cage we each had to drink 12 Beers
and get in the cage and and it was a
joke it was a joke I was [__] around
with Tommy I never thought I never
thought I'd meet style Bender I never
thought
that [__] rolls up to my show in
New Zealand and and first of all he's
way bigger than you think
okay
and he's and his hands are huge and
they're soft
and the first thing he does Joe is he
grabs my arm to like that me up and he
throws a knee and he gabs me by the back
of the night he goes you still think you
could [__] me up
and I'm like I'm so sorry I'm so much
but you know what you know what
that guy is the coolest [__]
like the coolest I mean he's one of my
[__] where I go he treated
everyone as if he wasn't the
middleweight champion of the world he
treated him as if he was just some guy
that was into comic books and and into
into anime and he meant Jared Hess the
director of uh Napoleon Dynamite was
that my show and uh he geeked out he was
like oh you didn't bully and dynamite
and Jared Hess is going this is Israel
I'm saying it like holy [__] and then
and then Joe
and
I Izzy I'm sorry if I tell you I talk
too much sometimes
I'm we end up at a bar at like three in
the [__] morning and he is I'm faded
I don't know if he was drinking too much
at all I don't even know if he's
drinking
it and
but we get pretty we get pretty lit
in a bar at three in the morning New
Zealand and he stands up and I stand up
with him back to back shirtless both of
us
and we challenge everyone in the bar to
a fist oh you have it
oh this is uh what are you challenging
ever in the bar
who won it
what are you doing here challenging a
bar to fight and this isn't another
country
Jesus Christ Bert we were [__] dude
this [__] is the coolest guy in
the [__] world he goes he literally
is he stands up and he goes how who has
that he's one of the coolest guys that's
ever lived in his Twitter oh it's on his
Twitter oh [__] look at this he goes he
stands on me goes and his first words
out of his mouth I'll kill every
[__] in the room for this man
right here so then you know my shirt
comes off I go okay I thought we were
doing a Steve Harvey bit you ever seen
Steve Harvey talk about his wife
oh
that'll make you cry because I know how
you unless you love your wife
is his his wife's name is Marjorie
is I thought style Bender was doing a
Steve Harvey bit because Steve Harvey
has this moment where
he's doing award show and he hears a
song and he goes oh I'm having me a
moment and he goes That's our song and
then and then it's and it's it's a cool
moment he goes She's mine oh this is it
this is it this will make you cry man I
mean I get emotional watching this
and that's me and my
oh
I met her 86 87 when the song came out
then God gave her back to me in 2005.
I put her name on the back man you you
understand me
that's mine right there
yeah I own you and you own me
I will kill everybody in here about your
ass please understand that about the way
I love you Marjorie Elaine you
understand me I kill everybody in here I
swear to God I thought he was doing I
thought he was doing it because he goes
ask the Lord about me I killed her
[__] idiot
that's hilarious so you thought style
Bender was doing that because Leanne
sends me Steve Harvey clips and she just
sent him and I thought he must have seen
the clip it must be going viral oh
he's mine and I'm him
we started going I thought he was doing
Steve Harvey and so oh my God and then
we start going table to table Joe we go
table to table challenging [__]
who wants it look these look at these
big dudes behind them these big Samoan
guys we're like who wants it who wants
it and then I should have gone horribly
wrong I was challenging the female
tables exclusively what if there was
rugby players there or something he's
the middleweight champion of the world
I'm gonna stand my [__] ground oh my
God that's so dangerous we ended up we
ended up buying the whole bar shots oh
that's good three times whoa filled them
up [__] around them up in a drunk place
it was and then he texted me the next
morning like like boom he's out he's out
he didn't I don't think he drinks as
much as I do and that that dude I'll
tell you I'm a ride or die for him he
was the nicest we sat and talked we just
talked about like you know something
really important in life is celebrating
like celebrating victories I love the
way he does that I really do when he has
a victory he goes on like a celebration
tour and and I feel like the the
universe universe then [__] is set
right